let's keep that round of applause going
for team three
all right hello everyone we're group
three my name is joey this is miss robin
of course juan and julianne
so
we're group three and we have a vision
of the education system where schools
are tapping into the human capital that
already exists in the community so what
we propose to create is what's called
the communal school mentor database so
it's a place where teachers students and
professionals who are living in the
community can connect onto one digital
platform so we're going to show you how
the the website would actually work
okay so say i'm on the communist school
website the mentor database and so i'm a
student so i'm going to press students
so um
what will show up after um let's say i'm
really interested in architecture i want
to know how things are built um the
plumbing the electrical wires all that
so i'm going to type in architecture
here and then it'll come up over here
then i'll click on architecture
so uh the results are a couple people
that like mentors um professionals that
um
have expertise in um architects so i'm
going to click on jane a doe
jane doe her company is mvp she has 10
years of experience she likes cats and
dogs
so
i'm gonna go connect via my school
so yeah
and so i'm a teacher and i have to meet
the common core the next generation
science standards
so to do that um in scientific and
technical writing i am going to match up
my students to a person who could help
either my gifted and talented or my
special needs student in a format that
works mentorship or what
and i am the professional i'm the person
who's looking for ways to help students
but i really don't know what to do and i
am trying to desperately find ways okay
so i log on to the system i put my
information
i talk to the school district and i
connect
thank you
thank you so much team three that was
great let me have you scoot on over
to our panel of people in funny haps
question on the interface between
um
from the student's perspective is it
filtered through the teacher monitoring
yes okay yes we would do background
checks yeah on the professionals that
would do the eight weeks all of that yes
and the parent would actually get an
email what's the mechanism for
the professional
to be
to be listed yeah so basically you know
every every player has is going to have
their own profile so you know we tried
to represent how each page is going to
be different so when he makes his
profile he's going to say you know how
far am i willing to travel what are my
skills um what can i bring how does he
know to do that though what's his what's
the dissemination dissemination
i mean going through um professional uh
unions um
lawyers bankers engineering associations
et cetera to pull in and also really
fraud based and then it also goes to the
underemployed too so these could be uh
opportunities for those who want to
contribute and are doing other work
example engineers like me who are in
education now who still want to teach
math and it's also going to be on a
face-to-face level the idea is going to
be spread so imagine a
a time where you're at a parent-teacher
conference and you know someone says oh
you know johnny's doing great and um
next week we're actually going to be
starting um cardiology like oh you're
you're a doctor like you know you're a
cardiologist that's great like do you
mind coming into the school oh here's an
application are you on our mentor
database you know that's sort of
that's the informal interaction that
happens sometimes in schools where you
know well there is this motivation
exactly whatever so that connects to the
common core a kids want theory to
practice right so the teachers are
providing that theory and they want to
see these things in practice and that's
where the kids come in but also go ahead
and it's student motivation so you know
as educators you know a very frustrating
problem is the kids saying when am i
going to use this so the real the big
part of this is saying taking the
fundamental skills that your teachers
are teaching you and
looking out and saying okay so what
skills are these being applied to what
fields what industries and i want to
connect to them